we don't know who leaked the draft of
the supreme court opinion that overturns
roe vs wade and planned parenthood
versus casey was it a clerk a justice
well either way is someone going to jail
well the supreme court operates in
secret famously they don't even allow
cameras or video recording during the
oral argument but nothing the supreme
court does is classified and it doesn't
appear that there's any specific law
that makes the leak illegal and leaks
have happened in the supreme court
before the rogue decision itself was
leaked before it was public as was the
decision in dred scott and there are a
bunch of books from after the fact from
insiders and clerks like eddie lazarus
and jeffrey toobin so supreme court
leaks happen but they are pretty rare
this one might be the most public and
justice robert's head is certainly going
to explode but there may not be any
criminal liability for someone who did
it so to paraphrase law professor steve
vladick the link is a story but it's not
the story